How popular is the Green New Deal, a
sweeping proposal designed to address
climate change? The proposal, put forward
by Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and Senator Ed Markey, has
received lots of attention in Washington,
but a large swath of Americans are not
familiar with it. 41 percent in a mid-February
online Economist/YouGov poll had heard
nothing at all about it.
Around a quarter – 24 percent – had heard a lot,
and 36 percent a little. In
the same poll, when asked how they felt
about the Green New Deal, people were
split — 23 percent supported it while 24 percent
were opposed. A substantial 39 percent were
not sure. Rank and file Democrats were more
enthusiastic than Republicans about the
proposal, with 42 percent of Democrats
supporting it compared to just 8 percent
of Republicans. A Politico/Morning Consult
online survey also found deep
partisan divisions. Americans are
increasingly concerned about climate
change, but it is too early to say how
the Green New Deal will ultimately fare
in the court of public opinion.
How much do you know about the Green New Deal?
Let us know in our poll. Also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.